this video is brought to you by audible
[Music]
hey wisecrack Helen here so Jared's on
vacation which gives me the chance to
tell you all about the philosophy of a
show about philosophy
this could get meta the good place is a
fascinating piece of television because
while it includes philosophy lessons as
a major plot point it also incorporates
its own ideas on human nature fate and
ethics for a show ostensibly about
teaching people to be good in the
afterlife the good place asks a more
profound question can those lessons
actually make us better people and if
they can does that matter
welcome to today's much requested
episode on the philosophy of the good
place spoilers ahead okay so a recap for
any uninitiated into the world of the
good place the premise of the first
season is that co-worker betraying
senior scamming tequila slugging human
garbage
Eleanore shells drop dies and
accidentally ends up in the good place
there's been a big mistake I'm not
supposed to be here which is basically
heaven except without all the religion
II stuff which weirdly makes it way way
more elitist only the very best to get
into the good place based on an intense
point system to determine exactly how
good you are you need me to lie to old
people and scare them into buying fake
allergy medicine I get it man which
one's my desk
even though Eleanor probably doesn't
belong in any religions good place the
point system gets absurd every single
thing you did had an effect that rippled
out over time and ultimately created
some amount of good or bad she's joined
in her paradise neighborhood by to honey
a beautiful wealthy philanthropist John
you a Buddhist monk and her supposedly
soul mate Chiti a philosophy professor
specializing in you guessed it ethics
also there's a lot of frozen yogurt what
is it with you and frozen yogurt have
you not heard of ice cream oh sure but
I've come to really like frozen yogurt
there's something so human but taking
something great and ruining it a little
so you can have more of it although the
good place is supposed to be heaven for
Eleanor being surrounded by people who
are better than her
is actual hell after Eleanor tells GD
her secret that she's there by mistake
he decides to teach her to be a good
person by conjuring up a chalkboard and
giving her daily philosophy lessons this
leads to some of the best philosophy
jokes on television who died and left
Aristotle in charge of ethics Plato oh
and Johnny o is actually Jason a trashy
Florida wannabe DJ who is also there by
mistake so he joins in on the ethics
classes - this is your first step
towards not sucking cool I just have two
questions wonderful boy tryouts and does
this school have a problem oh no for
most of the show Eleanor's moral
progress runs parallel to her ethics
lessons
the more she internalizes philosophy the
more we see her making decisions that
are halfway decent if not downright
sweet the show at face value sets up the
premise that learning ethics makes you
act more ethically at least that's the
premise that GD and Eleanor are working
from as he goes through the grueling
task of teaching contractual ism to
someone who abandoned dog sitting duties
to go to a Rihanna concert you broke
your promise as soon as it wasn't
convenient for you and now I have a very
focused dog but that idea that learning
moral philosophy can make you a better
person is an ethical theory in itself
the question of whether or not ethics
can make you a better person and if so
what ethical system best accomplishes
that is called meta ethics
[Music]
fundamentally the good place is a show
about meta ethics even as it presents
relatively straightforward ethical
theories through GT and when Cheney
teaches UX he goes hard well now that
you've become acquainted with
existential crises I thought we can read
death by philosopher Todd may sounds
like the perfect beat read eleanor gets
the rundown on Rawls Locke Lao Tzu Plato
Sidgwick Mill Hume Scanlon and quite a
few other moral philosophers including
Todd Mae who just happens to be one of
the philosophy consultants for the show
I spent time all these competing
philosophical concepts are meant to
teach Eleanor and Jason how to be moral
enough to remain in the good boys
but as any ethics 101 student could tell
you learning a bunch of contradictory
theories on what makes someone act good
does not actually help answer the
question how the fork should I act
Eleanor frequently expresses her
frustration with this but she keeps on
gonna prove you're not selfish here's
the perfect test there's something fun
that you want to do and then there's
something less fun that people are doing
for the common good from the beginning
of the ethics lessons these frustrations
hint that the real question isn't which
of these philosophers should I base my
moral system on but rather is this the
right way to learn how to be ethical in
the first place after all
gd's inability to decide anything driven
by his thorough knowledge of philosophy
is his main flaw i miss my mom's back
surgery because i had already promised
my landlords nephew that I would help
him figure out his new phone and don't
need the Chiti who once had a panic
attack during rock-paper-scissors
because there were and I quote just too
many variables as the show progresses
eleanor becomes a decent person GD gets
slightly better at making decisions and
Jason gets married to a robot well
that's enough out of you robot lover hey
that's really not a robot we're still
not sure if that last one has any secret
moral significance well you might say
hey T DS classes are helping it could be
argued that Eleanor and friends are
progressing in spite of his philosophy
class that's because there's a big
difference between learning ethics and
doing ethics and here's where we get
back to meta ethics those questions
about what morality actually is and how
we got to approach it there's actual
data to support the idea that studying
moral philosophy doesn't
make you more ethical contemporary
philosopher Eric schwitzgebel conducted
a study between 2007 and 2009 there
resulted in a maybe not so surprising
conclusion ethics professors do not
generally perform more ethically than
their non ethicist and non philosopher
peers in fact many of those peers
believe that ethics professors actually
performed less ethically than their
counterparts this is consistent with the
story of cheating who despite knowing a
buttload about ethical theory ended up
in the bad place because of the people
he unwittingly hurt through his struggle
to apply those theories this is why
everyone hates moral philosophy
professors oh did we mention the good
places really the bad place we'll get to
that too it's gabble also studied the
effects of university level ethics
classes on student behavior and
concluded that there is little to no
correlation between taking ethics
classes and moral behavior again not a
shocker we often see Ellenor struggling
to weigh competing theories when
deciding how to act IRL cut says that
lying is always wrong and I follow that
match so you can't even lie to demons
they're trying to torture us man we're
behind enemy lines when you pick and
choose when you're gonna follow them and
she's actually trying which can't
exactly be said a freshman and ethics
class the schwitzgebel said he even
showed that ethics books go missing from
the library more often than other kinds
of philosophy books all your own
conclusions on that one I might not have
been a saint but it's not like I killed
anybody
wasn't an arsonist I've never found a
wallet outside of an IHOP and thought
about returning it but saw the owner
lived out of state so just took the cash
and dropped the wallet back on the
ground okay that's really specific and
that makes me think that you definitely
did do that much of the show's comedy
comes from the absurdity of what moral
theory looks like when played out in
reality whether that's the panic of
indecision or the hilarity and gore of
the infamous trolley problem happening
with a real trolley here are the levers
to switch the tracks
make a choice
we see some of the clearest morale
improvement when the characters stop
weighing choices based on theory and
simply follow their gut which one of
these confusing French books will make
him normal again
it's not very easy I mean emotionally
he's all over the map right now and I
can't believe I'm saying this but I
don't think this can be solved with the
book this suggests that while the fact
that Eleanor is trying to be a better
person is certainly helping her make
better choices it's not the theories
themselves that do the work it's a
little more subconscious than that
Eleanor's progress might be explained by
a meta ethical concept called moral
intuition ISM moral intuition ISM argues
that it's our intuitive awareness of
what's right and wrong
not book-learnin that informs our
ethical knowledge that might seem to be
a problem for our main characters since
none of them appear to have any moral
intuitions whatsoever Plus here do you
have a ton of pre-orders here is your
first cut of the profits Oh mum I can't
believe you sold the t-shirts
does it help if they basically sold
themselves however there are more
branches of moral intuition ISM that
suggests intuitions can change while
memorizing hue may not zap Elinor into a
perfect shrimp free angel it does open
up a space for self-reflection that was
previously pretty closed off him I'm
kind of like a self-improvement kick do
you think you could help me out
teach me to get all horny for the
environment or whatever we could also
read the show through the rules of
Aristotle's virtue ethics the idea that
the best path to morality is by
following the example of virtuous people
the good place does seem to make the
case for the power of friendship but the
problem with this theory is that at
least in the beginning there are no
truly good people for many of them to
copy so GD teaching Aristotle is
actually pretty ironic things get really
intriguing when eleanor goes back to
earth at the end of season 2 from the
get-go she acts way more morally than
she did in her old life despite having
zero memory of the lessons she learned
in the bad good place this suggests that
those experiences whether with books or
with her friends have altered her moral
into
missions even though she can't remember
them sure she falls off the ethical
wagon once or twice I quit
eat my farts benedict cumberbatch but it
doesn't take a lot of prompting from
Michael the barkeep for her to seek out
some help
something about Eleanor is undeniably
different also I bet Michael makes a
mean screwdriver because of you know all
the torture and stuff although we aren't
really gonna talk about predestination
in this video the ending of season two
pretty much whacks you over the head
with their answer - can people change
yes they can however this comes after an
entire season of Eleanor in the gang
making similar decisions over and over
and over times 802 every time Michael
resets their neighborhood so although we
can make our own destinies changing
habits sure is a [ __ ] or [ __ ] son of a
[ __ ] although we over here at wisecrack
think that the good place ultimately
rejects the idea the teaching ethics
directly leads to more ethical action
it's not totally clear gd's lessons are
no joke and the most profound evidence
of that is in Michael who after just a
few weeks of lessons becomes a decent
person or at least an honorary person if
anyone's had to fight off predestination
it's that guy there's just one more
thing
one philosophical inspiration in the
good place that no matter how tangential
it is to our main argument we just have
to talk about the show gets a lot of
inspiration from a wisecrack favorite
John Paul Sartre so in season 1 the
finale reveals that they are all trash
humans and the good place is really an
experimental neighborhood in the bad
place where tejani Elinor Jason and
Chiti are meant to torment each other
for all of eternity
Michael the demon architect who designed
the neighborhood has a theory that for
carefully selected people will torture
each other far more effectively bad but
whole spiders we're trying out the new
butthole spiders ah they're enormous
Elinor unknowingly tortures TD by
forcing him to make difficult choices
his real-life nightmare we're trapped in
a warped version of Nietzsche's eternal
recurrence
oh cool more philosophy that'll help us
GD tortures to Hani by refusing to make
a decision to pick her over Ellenor a
reminder of the second-best status she
had with her sister
for death I could hide an objective
representation
I trust my audience my baby has a hat
yes well done - honey - honey maybe
knowingly tortures Eleanor by providing
a constant reminder of how much better
she is it's just so sweet and teensy
just like you hoped me that's fine and
everything tortures Jason because all he
wants to do is be himself and he can't
even tell people his real name I miss
being myself myself was the base also he
never got to see the Jacksonville
Jaguars win their division title last
year I'm not convinced that a life with
no Florida Dance Crew will ever be
scarier than ass crack meds but hey I'm
not a literal hell monster so what do I
know another way to read the first
season is a modern retelling a
philosopher jean-paul Sartre no exit in
it Sartre riffs on his famous idiom hell
is other people with three bags locked
in a room in the underworld who make
each other miserable through lies love
triangles and everything you could
imagine from people who ended up in well
hell and in season one the neighbors of
the good place managed to make each
other very very miserable it's important
to clear up a common misconception hell
is not other people because someone
brought their crying toddler to see
Deadpool but because in no exit and in a
good place
your eternal neighbors will bring out
what you hate most about yourself the
torture is predicated not by say
attending an eternal dinner party with
people who use the word mouthfeel but by
letting those people decide how you see
yourself leading to the ultimate
existentialist sin bad faith
the similarities to no exit don't end
with the dopes existentialist themes
some of the characters themselves have a
lot in common with their good place
counterparts Inez who describes herself
as a damned [ __ ] is pretty much the
1940s Eleanor except a lot worse she
turns people against each other for fun
causes misery wherever she goes and
thrives on her own selfishness Estelle
is a high society socialite who's
obsessed with her own beauty and wishes
desperately for a mirror she insists
that she does not belong in hell and for
much of the play refuses to believe
she was a bad person on earth I belong
in the good place the the real one with
the good people who do I speak to about
correcting this me and you're all very
well I would like to speak to your
manager
Estelle snobbishness about the working
class is more than a little familiar
just not used to dressing like a plumber
s but when you call it a female plumber
or is it a toilet suite or or clock
wench
in any case that's how I'm dressed
she also murdered a baby which to honey
has probably never done probably we
don't make any sense together
and yet when I'm with you I can really
let my hair down metaphorically speaking
of course I'd never have it up in the
first place Jeanne doesn't have quite
the same amount of overlap with his
counterpart garça but there are
certainly some character traits that
ring a bell
Garson is a coward which gets him killed
and GD is terrified of making decisions
which is just its own brand of cowardice
I'm sorry everyone I just have some
worries as well as some concerns that
could potentially turn into outright
fears oh there they go
there's now also remember how GD refuses
to pick to Hani over Eleanor totally
happens and no exit sadly there is no
Jason God that play would be so much
better with Jason so the good place is
initially a show about Hell being other
people and also a show about the
philosophy of philosophies of which
we're discerning the philosophy of also
probably something about cacti but the
real question to end on is this did
watching this video on the ethics of the
good place make you a better person and
if you didn't learn anything from this
video well don't say we didn't try to
save your ass literally he was stupid
many times and if you want to make like
your favorite anxiety driven professor
and get your ethics on consider checking
out audibles expansive collection of
audiobooks with a 30-day trial your
first book is free so you can check out
store and Kierkegaard's fear and
trembling not only does Kierkegaard get
meta ethical but he explores how to go
from being an every
day dirtbag to living an ethical life
and unlike other streaming services with
audible you own your books audiobooks
are an amazing sidekick in your downtime
as you arm drowned or hike or even to
make your daily commute a little more
tolerable so go to audible.com slash
wisecrack or text wisecrack to 500 500
to get your 30 day trial and your first
audiobook free one more time that's
audible.com slash wisecrack or you can
text wisecrack to 500 500 thanks to
audible for sponsoring this video
[Music]